- We had Jacob Elordi here.
I fell in love with him.
- [Cailee] I know, it's hard
not to.
- [Kelly] He's so great.
- He's so sweet.
- He's so sweet,
little Aussie boy, I was like,
"Oh my gosh, he's so sweet."
But one of the things that I-
first of all, how did y'all bond?
I'll ask that question first.
Just 'cause y'all didn't know
each other before this, right?
So you're playing these
intimate, you know, roles, right?
- Well, sometimes you get onto set,
and it's okay to meet on day one as-
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- We roll right into it.
But, you know, playing
Elvis and Priscilla,
I knew that we had to
have that connection,
and had to have that trust in each other.
So, when I found out he got the role,
I was so excited 'cause I loved his work,
but I didn't know how he was gonna be.
So, I basically emailed him,
and forced him to hang out with me,
be friends with me.
(Kelly and audience laugh)
- You will be my friend.
- I was like, "Do you
wanna go horseback riding?"
Because that was something
Elvis and Priscilla loved to do,
and he was so game and-
- [Kelly] I love that.
- [Cailee] Oh, yeah, that's us.
- Oh, I've been there, that's on Sunset.
I've done that.
- I know.
And the Hollywood sign.
- Yes, I've been there.
That's so awesome.
But it's kind of hard to
have a conversation though.
- Oh yeah, I know, it was so awkward.
He's like behind me riding a horse.
I'm like, "So what?
Are you close with your family?"
(Kelly and audience laugh)
On this like group horseback riding trip,
no, he was so great,
and he was so, like,
connected with the the horse.
Like, he's such a outback all like-
- [Kelly] Oh, like
an animal guy?
- Yeah.
- Yeah, no, I love him,
and one of the things I loved
about him that we found out
is he's an amazing photographer,
and my favorite picture he took is of you,
I don't know if you've read your card yet,
but I was like, "I hope
you get a copy of it."
I have to show this picture.
- [Cailee] Oh, I wanna see this.
- Oh, this is not one I've seen.
No, no, this is beautiful,
I've never seen that one.
It was another one that we showed,
but anyway, we could show it.
Oh, I've never seen
that one either.
(audience laughs and claps)
They gave us more.
Oh my God, he's such a great photographer.
- I know, that just was so special.
- There's this one and you
look like a first lady.
Like it's this one that they
showed whenever he was on.
It's so beautiful, and I just was like,
"I hope you get this picture.
He should send this to you.
This should be your Christmas present."
- I just love that he did that,
because we shot the movie in 30 days,
so I sort of have amnesia
when I think back on it.
So it's so fun to see those photos
and it was such a wild
journey we all went on.
- That's a month.
- Yeah, to finish the,
I know.
(audience laughs)
Only a month.
- I just got anxiety for you,
and it's already done.
(Cailee laughs)
I was like, "Wow, okay."